and I bet you all the lives were like oh
the Torso gets me to it that's what gets
me going because they see the statue
they're like oh the V the V
a Tallahassee principle has been forced
to resign after parents complained that
Michelangelo's statue of David is
considered pornographic and shouldn't be
shown to a sixth grade art history class
sixth grade why because she gets too
horny yep that's what it was they're
just saying it's offensive and
pornographic kids know what pp's is by
sixth grade I know right that's kind of
late yeah and it's just a naked dude
which ones that we in 1993 is is my is
uh statue Divi standing straight up
right he's got his [__] out doesn't he
have like a coat he kind of standing
like sexy I think he's like holding like
a deck yeah yeah he has a coat over his
oh yeah right
very classic image
you gotta Coke Zero in one of the most
prestigious and most notorious
sculptures ever created in Florence
isn't it that penis broken off anyway no
the penis is there but a lot of those
dicks got broken off because because
it's funny yeah yeah yeah no because era
a certain era they had to go through all
of them break off the dicks and replace
them with leaves yeah but it is fun
that's tight that's the only the only
problem about with that that ever like
came up from that was just going hey you
like that [__] stop looking at it he's
trying to accuse other dudes of being
gay
once you have to turn to that peach man
huh so uh literally
um
that's stupid there's not much more
information than that outside the fact
that the principal's names her name is
hope she was pushed out of Tallahassee
classical school this week after three
parents complained about the curriculum
that's all it took three two of them
said dude two of them said they wish
they'd been made aware that kids were
being shown images of the sculpture
first and one claimed it was
pornographic and they claimed the images
upset their children
wow their sixth graders have seen way
worse what do you think 100 that are
showing like the freaking that have the
libraries that are containing those
right the anime ones we love books those
are that's real yeah we did the article
on that one and you know
I mean or what about like anatomy books
or even like the like National
Geographic Star Wars like these are
indigenous tribes you got [__]
titties all yeah yeah that's
pornographic man that was the first
titties I saw is National Nat Geo yeah
nice 100 no no looking back when I was a
kid yeah they were nice now I'm like oh
yeah not my style your first set of
titties though they were nice yeah the
scarcity mindset of seeing tits you know
I like titties of all kinds still
he's lying but he's actually probably
it's
a tough time to be a teacher because you
gotta deal with not really like
educating but dealing with the [__]
opinions of parents that's probably the
hardest and you don't get paid enough to
deal with that [__] well they're taking
like you can tell that the parents are
like
oh this is our little moment like what's
going on with drag queen Story Hour
stuff so they're taking like that and
they're applying it to like this [__]
and it's like this is not that bro no
yeah what are you doing it's not the
same I mean the statue of David is
pretty gay and I remember when we were
growing up
um
I feel like when we were growing up
it was the opposite where no one wanted
to talk about homosexuality but I
remember seeing all these statues and
thinking these Greek and Roman dudes
were so gay because all they did was
create naked men and then it's like in
the future that's all they did and in
the future you find out they were super
gay that's why they thought they they
made more men than females because
they're they thought that the most
beautiful bodies were male bodies Bart
stand up let me see it this is why Joe
should be a history teacher how funny
would it be if like years later some
some archaeologists I'll cover your body
goes this guy was definitely super gay
we did carbon dating that should be so
funny you tell that he was definitely
gay but did they
but did they tell that to us when we
were growing up learning art history
they didn't they didn't say that [__] in
high school they didn't say like these
statues was
it was it was erotic art or like it was
like it was because the guys
Michelangelo and all these guys they
built it because they thought the male
figure was much more hotter than the
female figure I picture a thousand years
from now some guy brushing off like
[__] JoJo's outline he's got like a
fossilized laptop computer he's got his
hand on his dick and he's laying
sideways
like that they're like like oh yeah yeah
this one's definitely gay
foreign
wait so they you're saying that they
made those statues because they were
like Thurston after that image because
that was yeah that was no I mean it's
not like the way but the thing is they
believe well they also Drew um have them
with real small dicks because small
dicks to them is like classy you're not
an animal yeah finally dick dude you're
like a you're like a gross low-class
animal you hear that Steve Gross low
class that's all rumors
are fighting
[Laughter]
that's why all the sculptures were made
with smaller penises because that was
classic
it's polite isn't it it's more of a sign
of intelligent stuff because you would
focus on things that more intellect
versus the big monster animal you know
Savage another thing you can't control
fun fact fun fact the the first
bodybuilder late 1800s right the way he
decided to shape his body was based on
these sculptures because he would look
like and be he would look at it and be
like how come like guys don't look like
this because then guys of that era were
probably malnourished or whatever and so
he would use those bodies as a way to
like aspire to uh like have body goals
and then he set the trend for what the
[__] body looked like should look
like for men tried to shrink his dick
really yeah to be more polite he was the
first Rising grinder
4 a.m rise and grind he wakes up hustle
he did it every day dude every day so uh
what is kind of cool though is that the
mayor in Florence actually invited this
uh this principle to come and uh to
invited them to Italy to come see the
the Sculptra and also invited the
parents so they could get horny that's a
tight idea yeah that's a great idea come
and walk come and see the [__]
ancient porn so you can get so horny
come come see this artwork so that you
understand this it's not just
pornography I'm hearing open your mind
you [__] ignorant I know Jesus and I
bet you all the lies were like all the
Torso gets me to it yeah
that's what gets me going because they
see the statue they're like oh the V the
feed
was right
he was right chicks need to wear dark
back to Olive Garden so I could eat some
[__] authentic pasta that's right you
go to the if you go to the Italy Olive
Garden that's the real thing that's
Overkill
it's Americans can like go in there and
appreciate it nah nah they're gonna be
like where's [__] Domino's
don't give me this anchovy pizza [__] I
think if if they pay for their flight
they're gonna [__] they're gonna you
think they'll go I hope they show up and
then they complain to the museum curator
that this guy's dicks out hey what and
they're trying to cover it up with our
sweater what's going on
and then they [__] put glue on their
hand and put on the dick oh yeah oh [__]
damn not much else to say no no it's a
little dick stop saying little [__]
it's classy stop saying but is it is it
like a Christian thing like are they
like a Christian school and they're like
we don't want to see this heresy in the
case of this uh in this school
Tallahassee classical uh cool name
okay let me ask you this what do you
guys think about having about teaching
sex to kids you think it's [__] weird
how old well I think you tell me what
sex education right like we all got this
doesn't that happen in like sixth grade
sixth grade middle school yeah Fifth and
circle remember we had that in a
different way like the time we were
growing up they would [__] bring out
the projector they would have to take
these [__] like halfway like you know
translucent little things that show the
anatomy put it on this [__] light
projecting thing nowadays what do they
got they got they got a drag queen
[__] bending over the children yeah
they might [__] show like a page and
a book but the kid meanwhile is in the
back beaten off to like 4K videos of
like you know what I mean it's a
different world goal
yeah yeah it doesn't seem like school is
beating the internet to education 100
nowadays nowadays it seems like you
probably would have seen so much [__]
versus when we were kids yeah we didn't
see a whole lot dude when I was in like
the fourth grade I was looking at
pornographic material you pervert I was
dude you are and I'm bragging about it
bro I was straight up drawing titties
and then erasing them it's not about
drawing a body with Ken and then putting
a paper [__] bikini on a pencil a
[__] bikini on 100 but not in pen I
wouldn't be that [__] risky that's
risky business I would do it I have to
get caught up dude that's how you get
caught yeah no yeah you draw the titties
right and then you
you know you're doing the same spot and
then you're like yeah but then you're
erasing me perfect
now there's no imagination no more dude
I know they just [__] look at the
phone and go damn damn Tick Tock girls
and they can see them all every [__]
size shape and color these little kids
have no idea how lucky they are That's
crazy dude and they're gonna be they're
gonna be weird for it that's such over
exposurement but their parents look at
Michelangelo and think it's porno
exactly dude do you think about the
dopamine hits that little Timmy gets
when he goes on the Hub and he's just
watching something it beats off and he's
like I'm gonna do that [__] again I'm
not gonna go out I wonder what that does
to their mind because like it's not good
for us it was like a slow build but even
then our grandparents would probably
look at our generation and say oh
they're getting too much [__] it's like
the grocery store dude we don't have to
hunt anymore no right so but we're
bitching because we used to have to hunt
we had to get we had to chase down the
titties ourselves and find an old
magazine somewhere under dumpster or
some [__] we was hunting dude we were
hunting we were Hunters we were
scavengers together yeah I like this I
like this and now they have stores and
you can just get up and go into the
store and you get all the titties and
[__] asses you want and and it's all
very available and at low prices and
we're just jealous aren't we yeah at the
end of the day we're just we're haters
yeah we're haters dude back in my day
[Music]
foreign